thank you yes sir I have Carl mayor with
me in the studio she is the executive
director of the U.S Chess Federation
welcome Carol I would like to ask you a
few questions and I just learned myself
actually that the U.S Church Federation
has moved its headquarters to Saint
Louis so tell me more about this move
what are the reasons and what do you
like about the city sure U.S just
decided about a year and a half ago to
to make the move from its prior home in
Crossville Tennessee
for a variety of reasons first and
foremost you know St Louis is the chess
capital of the United States so we
wanted to be here to leverage a lot of
the activity that goes on here on our
our behalf
but it also became clear that over over
time crossfill had served us well but we
were having it a difficult time hiring
the kinds of staff and the skills we
needed in Crossville so our board voted
in December of 2022 or actually January
of 2022 to to make the move and that set
in motion a series of things finding
space and then of course selling the
building we owned in in Tennessee which
we sold last August
well I think you have a lot of new
programs going on and I've learned I
also learned that you worked in a
variety of organizations which didn't
have anything to do with chess so you
started to serve the U.S chess uh in
2017 so please tell me about those
programs and the how how do you
revolutionize us chess oh wow yeah so
revolutionize maybe a strong word but so
I was hired at a time when U.S chess was
going through a transition the
transition was because we had been a
technically a 501c4 organization which
is a membership organization it's a it's
a federal tax status and during the
prior years we became a 501c3 which is a
charitable organization and in order to
maintain your charitable status much
like the St Louis chess club you have to
meet your mission and so I was hired to
do a handful of things one was make us
more like a charity while preserving our
traditional activities of being a
membership organization and serving our
members having a rating system and all
so what we did was we put together a
fundraising team we developed programs
and some of our programs have been
supported by the St Louis chess club
most most notably our our women's
program and all of those things have
started to flourish and grow and and we
were reaching many many more people
because we're not just limited to the
members that we serve and so it's been a
really exciting time well talking about
the members could you tell me what is
your membership base and what is the
percentage of men and women who play
chess in America sure so
um this has been an amazing year for us
uh during covid we lost almost 50
percent of our members and in May 2021
we our membership bottomed out and we
started gradually climbing back and in
February this year we hit a hundred
thousand members for the first time
which was a huge milestone for us
currently our membership is about 12 and
a half percent female which is a very
very small percentage
we're working with our women's program
to try to grow and retain more women in
chess and I think one of the really
interesting
data points if you will that that
we've uncovered is there is never parity
in membership at any age between men and
women in U.S chess or boys and girls and
so the the Gap is the smallest at age
five and it continues to widen
um All Through the Ages and that's
really a difficult challenge for us to
try to solve and through our women's
program and through other activities
like art support for Title One schools
we're just trying to bring more kids
into into the game of chess and you know
some of them will be female and and
we're just going to keep at it until we
we see more parity
uh thank you and those are very
important initiatives indeed uh would
you be so kind as to share with us what
are the most important upcoming events
so you I I think Junior seniors yes
championships yeah so um the St Louis
chess club again this year is hosting
the U.S junior U.S junior girls and
Senior Invitational events in July and
then in October the U.S championships
the
um Women's Championship as well will be
held in October and we always love being
here in St Louis they do an amazing job
with every event they run
thank you so much girl I wish I could
play one of those tournaments
and hope to see you soon very good thank
you Carol first of all congratulations
uh just one quick question before you go
um covet impacted everybody impacted
your member organization but for me one
of the most spectacular events I've ever
attended was the Super Nationals in
Nashville did you miss a supernationals
did the USCF miss the super Nationals we
did the the last supernationals was to
have been in May of 21 and as you know
things were still very uncertain and
some of our youngest players weren't
even eligible for vaccinations at that
point so we we had to cancel it but we
have one on tap for 2025 in Orlando
Florida so we're looking forward to that
and we expect it to be really really big
probably 6 500 or 7 000 players wow wow
well again congratulations thank you for
everything you do and especially to the
executive board as well for your
leadership
I attended the super Nationals
I was overwhelmed it's just so
incredible very natural there were I
think 5500
children yeah
participating it was so much fun
coaches and parents uh Galore it's it's
fantastic